you were talking about
how you felt about the peterson debate
and he said i think we just left off
there
yes so okay so yeah this conversation or
whatever we want to label it so this
transcending kind of experience that
just sort of reveals itself when you
feel you know you're you're
you are in touch with something
transcendent that makes
you transcendent you know that there's
you're you know larger than life
something more
um than people who don't have this
experience
um this is look there's a very
intoxicating feeling
i'm extremely
wary of it that because um
you know i i think that in fact that
that is
partly that that is a mechanism that can
go
uh very wrong
morally wrong and people who
um not to put to find a point in it
the nazis preached just such a thing
when you were at these
these at these rallies and you were part
of this
um you know greater
greater than you know the destiny of the
german people
you know and it's it was just
self-revealing and
it says you know was such a powerful
feeling it's a kind of religious feeling
i mean religion has can have that as
well when you
feel yourself chosen by god or god is
with you you know it is just this sort
of
self-revelatory feeling
i mean sometimes it can be in in self
lifting and you're an uber match you're
more than human
i hate anything that makes us more than
human i'm very
wary of it um i know it's
enchantments i know it's intoxications
um i think human is enough
really human is enough understanding
your humanity and the humanity of
everybody else and how
the same we are um
that's a much safer uh
way to feel and and and it is
it's it's it's uh there's nothing
grandiose there's nothing
self um deceptive
about it um it is so anyway i
i all of my
alarms were going off um
between these two people between these
two men um
both of whom you know i think craig
realized that i was one never mind i
wouldn't know i'm gonna go there but um
so um but um
you know on the one side you know
somebody saying you know believe as i do
or your life is you can't even be a
moral creature
you know you can't have no meaning you
can't um
have no purpose and um on the other side
this sort of like
you know self you know this
transcendence that reveals itself and
and it reveals itself and it's the
experience itself so if somebody tries
to talk you out of it or something and
say look this is
taking you in the wrong place no it is
self-um
proving self-authenticating
this this is anti-rational and this is
for me danger
so both of these people all my alarms
were going off
ah this is precisely
these are the things i don't believe in
um and i and i see
dangers in both of these sorts of things
i see
suffering suffering coming
uh from from trusting your feelings of
self-transcendence or
danger coming from thinking here this
way is morality
other people can't be moral right which
makes them
less than human so either be more than
human
or you're less than human i okay
i think i've said enough i don't believe
i i
this is goes against everything i
believe in i see i see now
with respect to morality are you more of
the sam harris type that would say that
we can derive
morality from something objective or
scientific or fact based i mean
um science
i am more with harris than not that is
um i believe
morality is objective yes i do um
i don't think it is the same thing as
science um i don't think um that
and i and i'm not a utilitarian as a
matter of fact um
i i don't i don't hold by that theory um
of morality i think that
perhaps sam um i haven't discussed this
with him i would like
to discuss it with him more um is um
too hasty to go from
um morality
has to do with human well-being
to utilitarianism right that that there
there there are other alternatives not
where you dismiss human well-being i
think he says about
rawls a kantian theory that i take quite
seriously
um that it is it's it's us
it it's separate from it doesn't think
of
human well being that this is not true
this is certainly not true
but it does you know there are other
alternatives you can think that
morality is objective uh that it has to
do
with human flourishing flourishing of
all
um and not being a utilitarian
um and there are tremendous problems
with utilitarianism
um i do think there's a way of deriving
you know ethics and the fundamental fact
of ethics
which is the equitable distribution of
mattering over all humans
which is not to say that only humans
matter uh but it is to say that all
humans matter right other
things matter to other sentient
creatures matter to the planet matters
works of art matter all sorts of things
matter that aren't
humans uh but that um
all humans do matter and that's where we
get into some of the problems with the
utilitarianism you know can you
sacrifice an innocent if it's going to
be good for the you know in general if
it's going to maximize well-being
for everybody or there's some things
that just
can't you know if the fundamental
fact of everybody's mattering in the way
that we know ourselves to matter and
certainly the ones
who that we love matter um
then we run into certain problems with
utilitarianism but so anyway
that's basically all i would say i'd say
moral
theory is very very difficult how does
how is it how are morals objective like
how does one make an objective
case for morality okay
um there are certain
fundamental justificatory
principles that we use in logic
in the rules of deduction in empirical
thinking the rules of
induction and abduction that give us
the concepts of evidence
right and deduction that gives us uh the
concepts of of
proving things you know of a logical
consequence
and also in um in practical reason
right in uh in pursuing our lives
um and we cannot
justify this is a kind of content
argument
we cannot justify any of these
justificatory principles because
they are the means by which we justify
in these various fields
if i try to prove logic
i'm going to have to use logic it's
going to be circular
all right that's where descartes got
himself into the famous
cartesian circle um david hume
great uh enlightenment thinker
um showed us that empirical reasoning
you know just thinking that the universe
is law like and so
using certain observable things as
evidence for these laws on the basis of
which we make
predictions which we use in both
induction and
abduction inference to the best
explanation
um that that presumption
that underlies all of this scientific
reasoning
um cannot itself
be justified because you can't justify
it through
deductive reasoning a lot of
and you can't use empirical reasoning
because empirical reasoning
presumes the numerological
nature you know that nature is alike you
know that there are laws right so if we
find an anomaly if newtonian physics
doesn't accord with our observations we
don't say oh well maybe
nature's just not well like no we go
back we fix
our approximation of what the laws of
nature are
these so you know in
all of our reasoning in logic in
empirical reasons
we there are certain things look we
these are the principles that we're
using
and we can't pursue
a coherent life without using them
right in practical reason as well
i cannot pursue my life
without thinking you know that i matter
you know if that my pain matters you
know that if
i'm so you know if um
i put my hand on a hot radiator and it
hurts
i've got reason right to remove it or i
you know if something's going to be good
for me in the future
you know then i launch my plans and try
to get there you know and and then and
then all of my emotions as well you know
it's
all wrapped up you know when i feel
frustrated or happy or
gratified or um hopeful or fearful or
anything
all of this is all presuming you know my
life matters
so you know in some sense i can step
outside of my life and say yeah does it
really matter
um you know maybe i'll decide it doesn't
and then i'm going to
go into some sort of nihilistic funk
because my mattering matters to me
so much that even
thinking that i don't matter you know
is going to you know get me into a funk
you know
because that itself is a testament to
how much you know we all our lives
matter to us we can't pursue them
without that's sort of the kind of
justificatory mechanism that we
use in pursuing our lives we can't
coherently pursue our lives just
as with that logic for that empirical
reason
we can't pursue our lives without
feeling that way back
i think you might think well what is it
about me that makes me
matter so much i mean it can't possibly
be just that i'm just me
because everybody else feels the same
way about them
well maybe it's because um you know i
belong to the right people
uh the right country the right this you
talk to enough people who um
maybe i have the right race the right
complexion right
um well you know slowly slowly
those ideas have been knocked down right
that's
progress right um and
um you know basically what you would you
come after look i can't pursue my life
without just the presumption that i
matter
same as everybody else right and so
whatever
whatever mattering i do have or don't
have it's equally distributed